hey leute minecraft 1.3 ist vor ein paar
minuten erschienen sap hat sich noch bei
twitter gepostet aber ich wollte euch
nur kurz durch dieses video eben
mitteilen das ist soeben erschienen ist
ihr unten steht minecraft 1.3.1 hier
habt ihr schon die ganzen neuen sachen
dies ergibt in den kompletten
einstellungen ich kann mir jetzt noch
mal eben eine neue welt machen aber da
wollte ich euch jetzt eben fragen denn
dieses video ist mehr dazu da dass ich
euch kurz zeige dass es überhaupt schon
draußen ist also ich bin jetzt hier in
einer neuen welt ich wollte euch nur
kurz zeigen dass es überhaupt schon
draußen ist ihr könnt es euch nun
runterladen indem ihr einfach in eurer
minecraft gehen und auf update klickt
und ich wollte euch kurz fragen soll ich
wirklich noch ein video dazu machen was
jetzt wirklich alles neues weil ich habe
ja schon ein 1.3 video gemacht dass es
unten in den video antworten ich wollte
euch einfach fragen ob wir wirklich noch
ein video wollt was ich zu dieser
version 1.3.1 jetzt machen soll oder ob
ihr er sagt näher kommen das reicht dann
will ich das dann heute abend machen
also schreibt mir bitte in die
kommentare und jan eintrifft 1.3 es
draußen und ich wünsche euch viel spaß
mit dieser version
und schreibe es in die kommentare
und vielleicht bis heute abend